- Sans surprise, plusieurs
- Quelqu- Quelqu- Quelqu- Quelqs
de moins à payer quand on achète
notre première maison, ce serait
le bienvenu!
- Peut-être la première
chose de l'abolir pour ça.
- On devrait en changerla termi,
en réduire le coût.
- La taxe de bienvenue,
immobilières perçus par
les villes. Ils doivent être
payés quand une maison change
de propriétaire.
YVAN COURNOYER, président
- Je dois mettre 5 % de mise
de fonds, mais 5 % d'une maison,
disons, de 500 000, c'est 25 000
qu'il ajoute un 6-7-8-10 mille
de taxe de bienvenue, ça peut
acheteur.
- La cheffe du Parti libéral
permettre aux premiers
acquéreurs de souffler un peu
DOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe,
Parti libéral du Québecpar
le gouvernement li
100 % compensé.ond.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- On ne peut absolument pas,
malheureusement, sfinancement.
- Car ces droits de mutations
sont une revenus
importante.
Entre 800 et 900 millions
de dolla selon l'UMQ
qui lance elle aussi une mise
en garde : : : :
Les courtiers immobiliers
appuient l'idée avec réserve...
appuient l'idée avec réserveec .
DENIS JOANIS, président et chef,
Asso. prof. des courtiers, Qc
s la meills la meills la meills,
mais ça reste une bonne mesure.
- Leur association'il
faut d'abord améliorer l'offre,
donc augmenter le nombre de
propriétés disponibles ce qui
le marché.
- Il manque de propriétés
arché, il faut améliorer
l'offre. Donc, on peut penser à
des solutions comme le logement
des subvention, des meilleures
conditions pour que
retard du nombre de chantiers.
- L'idée de mettre au rancart
la taxe
pas d'hier, mais ce n'est
qu'une dses pistes
de solutions pour améliorer
l'accè
Ici Mélissa François,
Radio-Canada, Mon